like I don't know how brand to cardio
next stop care all right here in Cannes
we have tons of meetings entire
advertising industry globally gets
together here especially on the creative
side but ad tech fortune 500 clients for
me what's crazy is I'm able to get an
enormous amount of meetings in during
this week which probably saves me seven
to ten days in the second half of the
year of not having apply to Chicago or
LA or San Francisco or even believe it
or not New York I tend to see some
people here more than I see them in New
York just when you get to that level
busyness you know sometimes events like
this are just more efficient right so
we'll do that I'm looking forward to it
it should be really really productive
got a bunch of my team here Kim Garcia
from the Vayner experience crushed it
so excited about our experience division
of events that we put on and event so we
activate for clients
and the chip must be really good excited
alright cleaned up here a little bit in
the boat bathroom fully in the can load
now and super fired up to do our first
event here at the Vayner expo trainer XR
holding company that holds pure Wow and
vaynermedia
we're here in Cannes got a bunch of
activations line hardwood feel pure well
is here Beijing will be okay professor
row a bunch of boat to the left and from
the right
some people math a little bit left
they're more attracted some do some
panels now you want a sports jacket out
like this is not gonna not going to work
hard
[Music]
[Music]
convey what up baby how are you how are
you very welcome to me well yeah wait a
minute the rain is about the start I'm
your good brother I actually think it's
one macro which is this is a binary
conversation either an organization
cares about its employees or it doesn't
and and by the way I actually think the
way to hack this is to actually make
this a CFO issue not an HR issue I think
when people actually understand at the
highest levels that it's listen I'm a
good guy and I like people but like the
reason I'm obsessive about retention is
a create speed people know each other
cadence and speed wins you know business
is sports speed wins and so for me as
you know when we announced Claude is our
chief heart officer I started doing more
stuff on HR just gave a big speech in
San Francisco around HR when I talk
about people I try to make it more of a
CFO conversation because if you don't
it's fluffy it's emotional it's nice to
have if you make it financial everybody
starts paying attention so to me you
level it up to why maybe you give
somebody a raise that you don't want to
or you give them tickets to a Cardinals
game or you buy them some sneakers that
they've been liking on Pinterest or
Instagram it shows that you care and and
that leads to retention the biggest
reason I spent so much time one-on-one
with all the faces I see here people are
still here people that used to work for
me is because that caring are alive play
things out in a macro Shelly spoke to it
I mean you'll never
like somebody whose one that ever talks
about short-term return everybody who's
winning is thinking long term because
the ironic thing is business life and
life in general hopefully in clogs
nothing crazy happens is a marathon yet
everybody's running around like it's a
sprint trying to make something happen
in a 30 or 90 or 180 day window so I
think the hack is can you get into the
ear of the CFO can she or he really
realize holy [ __ ]
this action matters more than you think
and I think one I invest in a company
called high Q which is real big data
analyze a ssin of all this the cost of
replacing engineers in Silicon Valley is
so ridiculous even for me
with the people that I interact with
even if they're mid tier managers the
emotional cost of replacement is pretty
extreme and so that's where I would go
with
[Music]
I think about regret so much because I'm
fearful of it
I love life so much that when I'm 84 and
I know I don't have 30 years left
I'm gonna be sad and that's not the
reason I tell you this is here's a hunt
like this is like I don't know when
you're expensive our debits right but
the bottom line is it's always easier
now than it is tomorrow
yeah it just is I cannot hold you to
that lie behind a gun I'm gonna
implement I know it you're like I don't
even a hockey stick you saying your book
will be the greater I would [ __ ] hire
you you're gonna fail I'm glad I'll do
it just for a story we would run out you
know all right to stopping my trip to me
say well what is going through Utah
excreting - maybe attached to one of
your neighbors
[Music]
I'm having it going super well Shelly's
the beef dinner important issues you
know it's diversity and inclusion is not
about checking the box of being
politically correct it's a smart [ __ ]
strategy to win building good not Dennis
sources of growth a universally known as
dog edit that time
working in the dance studio
I think he embodies change changes the
change has been a bitten upward right
everybody talks about change I've been
to companies that this talk change but
changed took forever and market force
corrected them and with Gary I think he
invited change and he imposes that
mentality organically by the way on the
rest of the organization and I have not
seen an organization that was more
nimble and flexible in accepting change
pivoting adjusting adjusting to the
market condition suggesting to his
vision right because he has incredible
intuition and proving it's right or
wrong so I think that's also important
to be not to be Precious about your
change because change comes sometimes
it's a right change sometimes it's semi
right change sometimes it's outright
wrong so it's very important for
organizations to be able to go into that
change test it out and say two months
later that you know it was a mistake
we're pulling out we're changing it so
change I think and it's such a cliche
and it's something he says all the time
but I think it's it's a marathon and not
a sprint
I think this week it can is actually
probably one of the best representations
of that you know when you think about it
there's a lot of different people that
we're going to be meeting from a lot of
different companies and a lot of people
here thinking more transactional what's
the short-term opportunity how do I sell
them today how do I close the deal we're
the way that I'm thinking about it and
it's really what I've learned from Dairy
is how do I actually build a genuine
relationship with this person with the
idea that we might not do anything
together for two three four ten years
but ultimately I might want to recruit
that person ten years from now or I
might want to do a deal ten years down
the line or they're going to go talk to
their friend and say
hey I just met with the vaynermedia team
they're really really smart you should
be thinking about what they're doing and
so it's really just coming at it with a
long game mentality versus how do I make
the most money or close the deal in the
short term which is a total mind shift
for most people because they're innocent
for the short game versus kind of the 30
40 60 year game plan at the party
maverick doing his thing but you take
place
Kelly McCarthy she helped me build
vaynermedia in early days map cars was
great executives for the Franz Lloyd
house what is this event I think it
should happen again late in the night
Alex capital of homeless we've
established that my heart would need a
good amount tonight we may open some
[Music]
productive meetings Bryan productive
push you out over and out
[Music]
you